Okay, Michael.
So, we did supervised learning and
we did unsupervised learning
in randomized optimization.
>> Yep.
>> And the last section of the course
was on reinforcement learning.
>> Nice.
>> Now there's a lot of
stuff that we didn't cover
in that section of the course.
Which sort of makes me sad,
because that's what I do for a living.
I do reinforcement learning,
a little bit of game theory.
You do a lot of game theory and
a lot of reinforcement learning.
And there were a bunch of
things that we didn't cover.
Can you think of anything in
particular you wish you did mention?
>> Well I think the thing that most
people want to know about when
they hear about reinforcement
learning is function approximation.
The idea of can you apply
this idea to something
other than a three by three
grid world [LAUGH] right?
So to do that you often have to use
the ideas that we talked about in
the other sections of the class.
So use ideas from supervised learning to
learn something about the environment
that you are acting in.
>> Or even things from the unsupervised
learning section of the class.
>> Like feature selection.
And in fact, the notion of function
approximation is sort of a a special
case, maybe, the right term.
Attraction, a particular state of
attraction, action attraction,
this sort of notion of being able to
learn about one part of the space and
have it teach you about
other parts of the space.
>> Generalization?
>> Generalization,
in general, that's a big
part of making reinforcement
learning work in the real world.
Speaking of which, there's POMDPs.
We didn't talk about POMDPs-
>> Yeah, I get asked about that a lot.
So, should I say what it is?
>> People on the street walk up to you
and say POMDPs what's that all about?
>> It's surprising.
>> So
why don't you explain what POMDPs are?
>> Usually it's after class,
when I'm talking about something else.
>> Oh, well that I believe.
>> So partially observable Markov
decision processes, right.
So when we talked about without the PO.
MDP, yeah, all right.
So when you talk about MDPs,
the agent always has complete
information about what
the current state is.
That's the state is what you're
using to decide what to do.
The policy maps state to action.
But in reality, you don't really
have complete state information.
If you're a helicopter and
you're flying through the air,
you have to decide what to do based
on what you can sense right now.
And there may be even uncertainty about
what's actually going on around you.
>> Right.
>> And so,
you can't just use state information,
because you don't have it.
In the POMDP world, there's a separation
between what the actual world has
as its current state, and
what the decision maker knows to be
its perception of the state,
and those can be out of whack.
>> And that makes sense, I mean we live
in a world where we don't know what
is happening for every atom in the
universe that might have actually met.
So you know there's a whole other
class of problems that I wish
we could have talked
about that we didn't.
And those are all the ones
that involve humans.
>> Yes.
>> So
a lot of game theory is mathematical and
abstract.
But really it's about trying
to understand human behavior.
Right.
In fact there's been
a bunch of work done on bringing in
behavior into the game theory and
game theory into behavior and
marrying economics, game theory,
sociology, marketing, and-
>> Psychology, right, yeah.
I mean, behavioral game theory
is one of the names for that.
Though neuroeconomics also comes up
as a word that just seems like it
shouldn't be a word.
>> Yeah, that feels kind of made up.
Except of course-
>> I will pay you in brain cells.
>> [LAUGHTER] I'll get those brains.
>> That's the currency that zombies use.
>> [LAUGHTER] Okay, so there's a lot
about that with people with game theory,
and even in reinforcement learning,
there's been a huge move.
Actually, dating back decades, but
really has exploded over
the last four or five years.
>> Well in fact, what is the name of
school that you're in at Georgia Tech?
>> The School of Interactive Computing.
>> Yeah. That's it. Interaction turned
out to be a really important thing to
some people.
>> Right.
So, a lot of my work and reinforcement
learning, in particular, has been
about bringing people into the loop.
Learning from people,
watching what people do in
order to do feature selection, or state
abstraction, or just simple learning.
>> Some of my best friends
care about people.
>> Are you saying I'm your best friend,
Michael?
[SOUND] Very good, very good.
Okay, so
there's a whole bunch of stuff there.
[CROSSTALK]
>> No, I said some of my best friends.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You are some of my best friends.
>> I am some of your best friends?
>> I don't know.
But the point is that there's
this interesting line that happens
when you start thinking about
how these learning systems are
interacting with people either once they
start to behave in the world or
just during the learning process itself.
>> Right, because in fact,
in practice that's how we teach it.
So obviously we can talk
about this forever.
>> Yeah.
I'll just mention one,
let me just mention one buzzword.
>> Okay.
>> So, inverse reinforcement learning is
one that I particularly like.
We talked about reinforcement learning
in the class, where you take a reward
function and an interaction with
an environment and you create behavior.
An inverse reinforcement learning
goes in the other direction.
No, you start from
observations of behavior,
interacting in an environment that some
expert is doing, and you try to guess
what the reward function was that,
that expert would have been using.
>> Or a reward function that's
consistent with that behavior.
>> Exactly.
because you can't know,
really how rewarding is it to say,
get groaned at when you make a pun.
But you can tell that it's
obviously more rewarding than not.
>> Right.
But reward function, and reward function
times seven is basically the same thing.
>> Yeah, because you can scale them and
it doesn't change what
the behavior looks like.
That's right.
So what we take away from this is some
representation of the motivations,
desires, of the individual who
demonstrated the behavior, that we can
then transfer into new environments and
get good behavior out of that.
>> You know,
I think it's broader than that.
It's even broader than that, which is
really you can think of this whole
learning framework as kind
of programming framework.
Software engineering.
Where reinforcement signals are the
mechanism by which you program the agent
in order to get some particular behavior
as opposed to simple function calls.
>> I like that topic,
in fact, I think we should write
a grant proposal about that.
>> Let's write a grant proposal.
Maybe a paper in triple x.
>> Nice.
>> Let's do that.
So look I think it's obvious we can talk
about reinforcement learning forever
even though we didn't spend a lot
of time on it in the class.
Because there's all these basic things
you really have to get about supervisory
and unsupervised.
>> But how can we get all
this information out there?
>> I can think of one way.
>> Mm-hm.
Direct brain interface.
>> No.
>> Okay.
>> I mean yes, but no.
>> We could do another class.
>> You mean, like together?
>> Yes, we could do a whole class on
reinforcement learning, game theory and
explore all these ideas.
>> But who would even
want to come to such a class?
>> Everyone because we're going to
make it required [CROSSTALK]
>> Oh!
That's great!
>> Mm-hm.
>> Let's do that.
>> Let's make a class on
reinforcement learning.
>> Yes, we'll do a nice three hour
course on reinforcement learning and
game theory, and we can come back and
do all the same thing.
We can use the same editor.
>> Yeah, though it's very
possible that he'll cut this out.
If we even talk about it.
>> [LAUGH] No we'll use the same edit,
push car will be there.
It'll, we'll get the band back together.
>> Get the band back together again,
that sounds really fun.
And the groupies can be the same.
>> Yes.
We can have exactly the same set.
So, you want to do it?
>> I think I would.
>> Let's shake on it.
>> Let's do this thing.
>> Done.
>> Alright.
>> Well, then,
see you in the next class.
>> Yeah, we'll get started next week.